[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce grand
jt des territoires voici les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition confinement
des départements partiel localiser les
week-ends
nous ferons le point avec deux de nos
partenaires la chaîne de la voix du nord
ou égaux à dunkerque et nous serons
également en duplex avec denis carot le
directeur de la rédaction du quotidien
des alpes-maritimes à nice une météo
d'été peu commune en cette époque de
l'année
nous nous sommes rendus sur les plages
en provence et en occitanie vous en avez
bien profité vous lever à sur ces images
du vin de bordeaux au cannabis le croyez
vous les équipes de tv7 à bordeaux ont
découvert une cuve est bien particulière
vous allez découvrir du vin au cannabis
à boire bien sûr avec modération
enfin steve mcqueen est de retour au
mans nous nous rendrons en fin de
journal à une vente aux enchères pour
les passionnés d' affiches de cinéma la
chaîne lmtv dans la sarthe revient sur
les traces de steve mcqueen acteurs
mythiques les aussi pilote aux 24 heures
du mans
nous commençons ce journal en nous
vendant sur la côte d'azur qui vous le
savez fait l'objet d'un reconfirme en
partiel les week-ends
bonjour denis carot vous êtes le
directeur de la rédaction de notre
partenaire sur place nice matin alors
faites nous le point sur ce rush
confinement les week-ends mais
effectivement une nouvelle fois les
alpes-maritimes se retrouve dans une
situation inédite avec ce second film en
deux week-ends qu'on va qu'on va
inaugurer ici les habitants des
alpes-maritimes ont
on a l'impression d'être puni d'ailleurs
l'arrêté du préfet avant même d'être
publiés a déjà été attaqué les habitants
de ce département seront sont les cdd
mesure à répétition denis carot est ce
que vous constatez localement chez les
élus dans les alpes-maritimes des
différences d'appréciation quant à se re
confinement les week-ends il ya une
vraie fracture ici dans les
alpes-maritimes entre d'une part la
métropole autour de christian estrosi
qui souhaitent protéger les habitants au
maximum et les élus notamment de l'ouest
jean leonetti à antibes david lisnard à
cannes qui estime que le problème les
concerts de - le taux d'incidence est
moins élevé dans leur ville c'est un
fait et qui considère qu' il n'est pas
logique que des mesures globales soit
appliquée de la même manière à nice
antibes à cannes et dans l'ensemble du
département alors nice matin vous êtes
le média partenaire du grand jt des
territoires donc sur place dans les
alpes-maritimes
est ce que vous allez pouvoir et de
quelle manière et dé vos lecteurs les
gens sur place voilà à aller de l'avant
tout de même malgré ces mesures de
confinement que vous nous avez expliqué
alors on essaie d'accompagner les
habitants au quotidien nos lecteurs les
internautes et on le sait très
concrètement à travers un service de la
rédaction qui s'appelle la rédaction
répond qu'ils répondent en direct toute
la journée on aux questions qui sont
envoyées ça fait l'objet d'une rubrique
spécifique sur internet qui génèrent une
audience extrêmement importante et c'est
un service que nous mettons à
disposition de nos lecteurs d'un journal
papier aussi à travers une page
quotidienne où nous répondrons aux
questions très concrètes qui se pose à
chaque fois que des mesures sont sont
décidés à baisser
merci beaucoup denis carot vous étiez en
direct alors je crois vous étiez dans le
var à lagence de de var matin qui
appartient bien sûr au groupe nice-matin
merci de nous avoir précisé ce qui se
passait dans votre département
mais le site il
et puis parmi les agglomérations
concernées par ce confinement
l'agglomération dunkerquoise qui se
retrouvent confinés pour les deux
week-ends à venir
250000 habitants sur une cinquantaine de
communes sont concernées l'objectif
c'est bien sûr de freiner la circulation
du virus notamment celle du variant
britannique dans le dunkerquois
le taux d'incidence est le plus élevé de
france avec 901 cas pour 100000
habitants le centre hospitalier est
saturé et le responsable des urgences
parlait déjà il ya quelques jours non
pas d'une troisième vague mais d'une
marée dont les coefficients dépasse tout
ce qu'on a pu connaître jusqu'à lors des
informations qui nous proviennent de wéo
la chaîne de la voix du nord et de
caroline fichten les élus du dunkerquois
aurait voulu l'éviter mais la situation
épidémique du territoire entraîne comme
dans les alpes-maritimes un confinement
le week end c'est olivier ferrand en
déplacement à dunkerque mercredi qu'il a
annoncé à compter de vendredi soir et
jusqu'au lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end les déplacements resteront
possibles pour certains motifs tels que
des achats de première nécessité ou
encore des motifs médicaux vous
connaissez ces motifs et les commerces
autre que les commerces alimentaires
seront fermés les centres commerciaux
d'une surface supérieure à 5000 mètres
carrés il y en a 10 dans ces deux aires
urbaines ne fonctionneront plus qu'en
cliquer emporté 250000 habitants de la
communauté urbaine de dunkerque et de la
communauté de communes des hauts de
flandre sont concernés le maire de
dunkerque qui voulait éviter en
confinement comprend malgré tout la
décision d'état
je comprends sa décision aujourd'hui le
centre hospitalier est dans un état
difficile
les soignants sont épuisés je comprends
un moment donné que l'état puisse
prendre cette responsabilité et je le
soutiens et je pense qu'il faut que
maintenant l'ensemble des dunkerquoises
dunkerquois adopte les bons gestes qui
nous permettront de sortir de cet état
difficile dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
en plus des mesures annoncées des
contrôles se poursuivront sur le secteur
pour vérifier que les passages
transfrontaliers sont justifiées
et puis tout près de lyss regardez ces
images d'une plongée nocturne à monaco
que se passe-t-il la nuit dans les rues
de la principauté dès lors que l'heure
fatidique du couvre feu a retenti à 19h
les réponses avec sandrine de
monaco info sur place
regardez la ronde s'est très bien passé
donc là on a terminé donc on a on a
rencontré des personnes qui soient finis
c'est leur travail donc été autorisé à
circuler après le couvre feu donc de 19h
ou des personnes qui avaient un besoin
période et puis nous nous intéressons à
cette jeune start up iséroise de six
salariés qui développe depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire
un test salivaire numérique associée à
un smartphone le test in past détecte la
présence ou non du virus et délivre son
verdict en quelques minutes il
permettrait d'apporter un dépistage
précis et d'écarter rapidement les
personnes contaminées sur le terrain par
exemple dans un aéroport ou une gare le
résultat deviendrait alors un
laissez-passer sécurisé et personnalisé
ce sont des images de laurie baillet
pour telegrenoble et avec la
multiplication des tests de dépistage en
france notamment à la recherche des
variants du coc vide
les infirmières ont vu leur métier
totalement se transformer beaucoup
d'entre elles passent leurs journées à
réaliser des tests pcr
regardez ce reportage à nantes de maxime
du show pour télénantes c'est toujours
les mêmes questions toujours le même
rituel pour cette infirmière
installée depuis un mois seulement
libérale des tests pcr comme celui ci
noémie peut-on réaliser jusqu'à 80 par
jour un travail à la chaîne loin de
l'idée qu'elle se faisait de son métier
ce qui est frustrant c'est qu'on n'a pas
le temps de discuter avec les gens
s'installent on les rassure rapidement
sur ce que c'est que le test et après
ben suivant quoi ça fait on fait deux
minutes par personne à peu près ce matin
noémie fait partie des trois infirmières
libérales appelé par ce laboratoire pour
dépister massivement à nantes nord
aujourd'hui les tests pcr occupe 70% de
son emploi du temps
on voudrait faire autre chose on
aimerait bien avoir des soins post
chirurgie on voudrait
car d'autres s'en sortir un peu plus ça
serait bien que coville ne représente
plus de 20% quan béton dans le box d'à
côté tiffany sept ans de libéral à son
actif et déjà près d'un an de tests pcr
au début ça a été compliqué parce que en
libéral on s'est senti un petit peu seul
ce n'est pas évident on n'est pas dans
une structure on ait un ou deux dans un
cabinet on n'a pas forcément le matériel
n'a pas forcément de deux protocoles de
prise en charge et puis au fur et à
mesure on s'adapte on se renseigne on
aujourd'hui je pense qu'avec le mandat
du recul on sait s'organiser on sait
bâle a annoncé prendre en charge une
personne coville ou de faire des tests
pcr
avec l'expérience tiffany a aussi appris
à convaincre les plus récalcitrants
et ça marche
après cinq minutes de négociations le
petit malo a fini par se laisser faire à
l'abri des regards extérieurs
une prouesse de plus pour ses
cosmonautes de la planète qu'ovide et
puis regardez ces images de la dépêche
en pleines vacances de février la
fréquentation touristique de leucate
station de l'aude très prisé des
toulousains restent très modestes
la faute aux restrictions sanitaires
bien sûr mais sur place les vacanciers
prennent un bon bol d'air frais et
oublient un peu le coronavirus ce sont
des images de clément gaci pour la
dépêche
écoutez pierre qui est touriste et qui
vient de bourg en bresse ça fait du bien
acquis sa caste période ou en venant de
une région de l'est où forcément semaine
faste période c'est ouais c'est sympa
c'est simple il suffit de la mer au lieu
d'aller au ski vu qu'on peut pas y aller
en plus donc voilà on reste sur les
plages du sud de la france regardez ces
images qui nous sont envoyées par nos
partenaires de la provence à marseille
cette année les vacances d'hiver se
passe à la plage cette semaine il suffit
d'observer un littoral très fréquenté
pour en déduire que les vacances
scolaires ou bien commencé et avec le
retour du soleil accompagné de
températures avoisinant les 20 degrés
c'est sur les plages que les riverains
se sont rués comme celle des catalans
que vous voyez sur ces images où se sont
rendus les caméras de nos partenaires de
la provence et puis on reste dans la
région du côté de la corse dans cette
période incertaine les boulistes souffre
aussi du manque de compétition une
absence de visibilité dans le calendrier
qui n'empêche pas les joueurs de se
retrouver sur la place pascal paoli
quotidiennement pour s'entraîner comme
vous le voyez
et puis ces boulistes tout en respectant
les règles sanitaires ont quand même un
but c'est l'espoir de disputer la 10e
édition du paoli attendu en corse comme
le roland garros de la pétanque et qui
est prévue du 10 au 12 septembre
prochain si les conditions sanitaires le
permettent nous entamons dans ce grand
jt des territoires des portraits
maintenant d'hommes et de femmes qui ont
su quitter leur région pour mener leur
carrière à paris mais qui gardent bien
ancré en eux même l'amour de leur
territoire
c'est le cas de ce breton tugdual denis
avec un prénom pareil vous me direz ce
journaliste passé par plusieurs
rédactions de magazines parisien
retournent régulièrement dans son
morbihan natal et tébéo la chaîne de
groupe le télégramme sur place l'a suivi
pas à pas regarder ce matin de décembre
tugdual denis retrouve les iodé de la
bretagne est également le coup yodé des
huîtres chez son ami olivier
ostréiculteur à pouvoir l'air
moi j'essaye de revenir le plus souvent
possible en bretagne j'ai deux manières
de revenir c'est soit je vais voir ma
famille et mes copains soit dans le
cadre de mes pige pour la revue breton
tu fais une dizaine de séjour en
bretagne par an les deux hommes se
connaissent depuis l'adolescence tuque
comme le surnomment ses copains sillonné
carnac et ses environs entre sport
rencontre de copains dévoile sur le
rivage carnacois le journaliste
politique doit valeurs actuelles
déconnecte avec la politique lorsqu'ils
fréquentent ses copains de bretagne
les gens se font plaisir
retour à la maison familiale à carnac
issu d'une famille catholique
l'un de ses frères est prêtre les
copains de tugdual l'aurait bien vu se
diriger vers cette voie
ce sera plutôt la philosophie puis le
journalisme avec une collaboration avec
le magazine bretons dès ses premiers pas
dans le journalisme
je voyais les affiches à la gare
montparnasse avec leur jolie une en noir
et blanc c'est souvent des portraits des
articles à celle ont aussi été assez
fouillée assez ambitieux assez osé
finalement comme ligne éditoriale et
donc j'avais toujours voulu écrire pour
eux j'étais rend extrêmement content
quand j'ai réussi à écrire le premier
article pro breton et depuis jamais
voulu m'arrêter parce que c'est une
manière de garder un lien quand même
avec avec la bretagne en 2028 dual denis
a écrit la vérité sur le système fillon
un travail qui l'a amené à côtoyer les
proches du candidat malheureux à la
présidentielle de 2017
justement il y en a un à quelques
kilomètres de la maison familiale
un breton pure souche florent de
kersauson on retrouva et sur les quais
de la trinité avec le frère d'olivier de
kersauson florent a été à l'école avec
l'ancien premier ministre
j'aime son courage sa franchise et sa
façon de traiter les sujets j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce qui fait la bretagne
coule dans les veines de tugdual denis
grand amateur de coucher de soleil
ces séjours à l'ouest lui permettre de
se ressourcer et de s'ouvrir sur des
horizons plus larges que son quotidien
et la politique à paris voilà après
cette balade dans le morbihan retrouve
en duplex de valeurs actuelles tugdual
denis bonjour tugdual alors expliquez
moi est ce qu'il existe une bretagne
études un état d'esprit breton
particulier lorsqu'on vit à paris comme
vous
oui je crois effectivement qu'il ya un
tempérament bros
c'est un mélange de calme c'est à dire
de modération sur le plan parfois
idéologiques parfois politique et en
même temps une rudesse le côté
granitique un peu du tempérament breton
qui fait qu'on est capable d'affronter
les grandes tempêtes
tugdual denis votre journal valeurs
actuelles s'est lancé dans un hors-série
le goût de la france des terroirs et de
la gastronomie
alors pourquoi cette cette ligne
éditoriale de valeurs actuelles
maintenant parce que si vous voulez nous
on part du principe que les questions
d'identité sont fondamentales or la
france vous pouvez pas la dissocier de
ces identités régionales
quand on voit au travers des terroirs au
travers de la gastronomie au travers des
dd comment dire des industries des
emplois des territoires des dmm de la la
topographie des sols etc
la géologie la france et multitude de
différences qui font un tout et nous
évidemment on ne veut pas occulter ces
différences régionales
voilà ma dernière question est ce que
vous imaginez un jour pouvoir quitter
paris
retournez dans le morbihan plus proche
de vos racines peut-être avoir une autre
vie écoutez très franchement oui c'est
effectivement un peu le but avec mon
épouse et puis pour le moment l'écart 9
ans mais peut-être y en aurait d'autres
après je ne m'imagine pas la vie sans
horizon sans perspectives
paris est une ville où voilà c'est très
compliqué parce que vous êtes sur un
pont de voir à plus de 200 m comme je
disais dans le sujet et moi le voilà
j'ai besoin d'horizon j'ai besoin de
perspectives
j'ai besoin de sentir l'odeur de la
pelouse mouillée le matin des embruns
l'après-midi de pouvoir voir des
couchers de soleil est effectivement qui
ont visé aujourd'hui que je suis sur un
jour de terminer ma vie en bretagne je
le serai le plus heureux des hommes
merci tugdual denis vous êtes loin des
épreuves du bac vous ce sera pourtant
les nouveautés des épreuves du bac 2021
un grand oral 20 minutes seul debout et
sans notes devant un jury le lycée jean
lurçat de bruit hier a fait appelle
d'ailleurs à un comédien professionnel
pour préparer pour entraîner ses élèves
il est déjà temps de réviser d'ailleurs
avec marie danielle rockowitz pour
viavoice
on va s'échauffer
un peu toutes les parties du corps dos
en tapotant ce sera la nouveauté du bac
2021 le grand oral 20 minutes seul
debout et sans notes fasse un jury et
les terminales du lycée jean lurçat de
bruyère s'y prépare grâce à un comédien
professionnel ce vendredi matin après
l'échauffement de la voix place à une
prestation en trio sur un sujet farfelue
car ici on apprend en s'amusant et on
utilise surtout les ressorts du théâtre
on peut assommer ses équipiers et ses
adversaires donc ne pas attraper le
regard des membres du jury ou des
personnes à qui on est en train de
parler pour pouvoir les plus
convaincants et puis surtout les obliger
à s'intéresser à ce qu'on est en train
de dire la posture le fait de rythmes et
ex terrain comme je le fais actuellement
le discours qu'on est en train de tenir
enfin toujours évidemment pour le
convaincre les 120 terminale du lycée
vont tous bénéficié de sept heures de
formation pour gagner peu à peu en
confiance
alors je suis absolument pas et alors là
actuellement mon coeur doit battre
environ 130 fait maintenant par minute
donc ça nous montre aussi qu'on peut
improviser et justement croire à ce
qu'on dit ça peut permettre de
convaincre ça nous permet aussi de
comment dire de sortir de notre zone de
confort parce que c'est vrai que prendre
l'oral devant tout le monde c'est pas
forcément des choses faciles camarades
nous posent des questions finalement ça
remplace les professeurs qui nous pose
des questions on a tous les contextes
qui sont représentés et cette mise en
scène est utile pour ses terminal qui ne
peuvent pas s'appuyer sur leur
expérience des oraux de français de 1ère
supprimés l'an passé à cause de la crise
nous est pas imaginer les envoyer face à
une épreuve sans les avoir préparés
d'où l'intérêt de ne pas travailler avec
des personnels de l'éducation nationale
mais d'avoir la présence parmi nous d'un
expert quelqu'un extérieur qui va leur
permettre de se dépasser
des ateliers qui devrait permettre de
réduire le stress car '
il de montants chesnais avec une
problématique étudié en cours répondre
au jury est présenté avec le plus
d'éloquence possible leurs projets post
bac 20 minutes seul et c'est long à
tenir le grand oral c'est aussi une
épreuve obligatoire en tout y en a cinq
qui contribue à 60 % de la note finale
bonjour michel picaud c'est le moment
d'en inviter de la rubrique écorégions
vous nous présentez une start-up qu'est
né à rennes on reste en bretagne avant
de s'installer dans les yvelines pour
développer la solution éducative
destinée aux enfants et adolescents
autistes
bonjour cyril bonjour à tous tous les
enfants doivent pouvoir apprendre
découvrir et gagner en confiance et
quand je dis tous les enfants je pense
aussi aux enfants et aux adolescents
autistes dont les programmes
pédagogiques ne sont pas toujours
adaptés d'où l'idée de gaël regnault
elle même maman d'un jeune enfant
autiste de lancer des manuels des
logiciels et des applications permettant
à ses enfants d'apprendre à lire écrire
compter et surtout retrouver confiance
en eux grâce à des programmes
spécifiques
les enfants sont aussi accompagnées pour
ses cours par des adultes pour suivre
ses cours que ce soit dans les écoles
les établissements spécialisés ou encore
quelques mairies ces cours peuvent être
donnés en présence d'un parent enfin un
espace activité adaptée permet aussi à
l'enfant de jouer seul learn angels sous
le nom de cette entreprise a vu le jour
en bretagne avant de s'installer dans
les yvelines
sachez que cette solution a été reconnue
comme une initiative pédagogique
remarquable par le géant de
l'informatique apple
elle a obtenu également l'agrément
gouvernemental en étant reconnue
entreprise solidaire d'utilité sociale
l'entreprise permet aux enfants de
gagner en confiance comme je vous le
disais et d'éviter aussi toute forme
d'exclusion liées à leur handicap
bravo merci michel picaud rendez vous
dans une prochaine édition du grand jt
des territoires direction les antilles
maintenant sainte marie dans le nord
atlantique où le tombolo est ouvert
depuis quelques jours
ton boulot c'est un phénomène naturel
qui ne se produit que quelques semaines
par an la bande de sable et de nouveau
praticable et les mains
cynique et ne manque pas d'en profiter
pour une balade sur l'île et sainte
marie entre amis ou en famille le
tombolo fait toujours son petit effet
vous allez le voir un espace naturel à
préserver comme l'ont constaté deborah
ambrose in et marc joseph luc da tv sur
place notre chaîne partenaire parmi la
quarantaine d'îles et de martinique
l'île sainte-marie fait partie des plus
visités et pour cause on amoureux en
famille ou entre amis quand la période
s'y prête pour s'y rendre il suffit de
traverser ce banc de sable le tombolo 60
voyagement champlitte la martinique pour
aller sur le petit gros coups de
cailloux est vraiment magnifique d'abord
les pieds dans l'eau arrivé sur l'île
est c'est une terre aride et sèche que
l'on découvre un lieu à l'atmosphère
particulière sa alu apaisant ou jeu j'ai
enlevé mon masque d'ailleurs c'est un
lieu qui est quand même très insolite y
en a peu au monde le mont saint michel
ici il ya une jupe est imprenable il ya
aussi des falaises qui sont toutes au
fond donc c'est vraiment un très très
agréable un lieu qui mérite d'être
visité un million de fois si nécessaire
seul ombre au tableau les quelques
déchets échoués aux abords la déception
elle évite la quand je vois les les
restes de plastique de part et d'autre
c'est quand même moins moi de faire
quelques efforts permettrait d'éviter
cette gêne et garder le lieu toujours
aussi beau car comme le dit si bien sots
et c'est quoi j'allais vous l'avez vu
dans les titres c'est à peine croyable
du vin au cannabis un jeune bordelais a
tenté le pari fou de créer un vin qui
contient des molécules de cannabis mais
sans propriétés toxiques alors que le
marché du chanvre est en plein boom en
france ce producteur a voulu diversifier
ses activités
en quelques mois seulement c'est comme
en ont évidemment explosé cet art
portage de baptiste monge et pour télé 7
la chaîne le groupe sud ouest à bordeaux
croyez-le ou non le fruit de cette
petite plante va aromatisés une
bouteille de vin un processus long qui
démarre sous cette serre alors là c'est
la première étape de la culture de
chanvre en fait on est en train de
réaliser les plaques de semis qui vont
permettre première coupe des plans de
chant en fait pour faire un effet
buisson sur la plante et avoir un volume
de fleurs ça va rester à auxerre et
ensuite ça va être difficile et
directement enclenchant ici les plants
de cannabis pousse sans thc la molécule
toxique aux effets psychotropes
il est donc légale d'en faire pousser
raphaël de pablo a eu l'idée de mettre
les fruits du chanvre dans du vin j'ai
découvert un article sur science a visé
avec une découverte archéologique où ils
avaient retrouvé dans une jarre du vin
en fait qu'il a été de 200 ans avant
jésus-christ où il y avait du coup du
vent et du cannabis
on a fait les essais c'était vraiment
assez surprenant en termes de goût du
coup le fruit du champ ça donne ça et
c'est donc ça qui va se retrouver là
dedans mais alors quel goût ça hein
alors je trouve pleinement le goût du
vin rouge plus particulièrement celui du
petit verdot qui est un cépage bordelais
oublier très présent dans son vin et
puis comme je vous disais vraiment c'est
sur le plan aromatique il m'intéresse le
plus ce côté venus d'ailleurs venue du
cannabis qui est là bien présent cette
bouteille coûte 34 euros et en l'espace
de quelques semaines les commandes ont
explosé passant de 500 à 10000
exemplaires
pour ce député le marché est une piste
d'avenir
face à lui de faire les choses de
manière sérieuse de pouvoir faire
évoluer notre réglementation pour
pouvoir effectivement développer les
usages du cannabis qui ne sont pas des
usages qu'ils peuvent être nocives d'un
point de vue sanitaire
si ce breuvage fait parler de lui c'est
aussi par son succès raphaël a déjà reçu
des demandes des états unis et d'israël
et pour finir ce journal voici un sujet
sur les fans de cet acteur hollywoodien
mythique qui fut aussi pilote une grande
vente aux enchères d' affiches de cinéma
a eu lieu cette semaine au mans en
vedette une affiche originale du film le
mans de 1971 avec steve mcqueen
elle a été adjugée 1200 euros et anthony
python fan de steve mcqueen seelandais
s'est rendu sur place pour bien lmtv
regarder on a bien sûr vous voyez le
film en une tournée en 71 homme-enfant
clément et paul maclean
l'américaine l'a également la fiche
française
il passera en vente cette affiche de
cinéma est estimé à 700 euros
elle sera l'apogée d'une vente aux
enchères exceptionnelle organisée au
mans près de 600 images seront proposés
à la vente
j'ai tout de suite vu que steve mcqueen
s'était c'était une légende ici au mans
vu qu'il est venu sur les 24 heures du
mans
c'est vrai que tous les manceaux ont
plus ou moins un souvenir de l'avoir
plus ou moins croisé donc ici c'est
iconique j'ai vraiment 3 4 lots autour
d'eux au tour de steve mcqueen déjà ça
fait ça fait un bon point culminant et
ça permet d'échafauder une vente très
correct les affiches présentent ils sont
très variés de nombreux films cultes des
films de la nouvelle vague ou encore des
séries b en passant aussi par les
blockbusters l'on cherche deux films
avec deux titres que je fume célèbres
les plus après c'est l'époque les
acteurs la salle des ventes peut
accueillir jusqu'à 30 personnes
les autres acheteurs seront derrière
leur ordinateur sur l'interface
interencheres points comme et les
affiche un ca se prête très bien à ça
parce que ce sont des multiples sauf
sont pas des produits uniques
donc au final il n'y a pas tellement
besoin de venir les examiner les
enchères sur internet permet aussi de
toucher une clientèle de la france
entière voire étrangères la fiche de
steve mcqueen pourrait donc
prochainement quitter le mans voilà moi
aussi je suis un grand fan de steve
mcqueen
merci d'avoir suivi le grand jt des
territoires on se retrouve
bien sûr pour une prochaine édition sur
vos chaînes régionales et locales de la
tnt et sur tv5 monde
bon courage à tous au revoir
[Musique]